it took four years to be
on the stage to get this trophy um thank
you so much
and actually this means to us even more
because we're
we're actually a small boy band from
korea
bts pays tribute to their beloved army
at the 2021 american music awards we
waited this for
so
so long time the k-pop group proved
their love for the fans is truly out of
this world thank you army and thank you
amen so much for this
wow
for threes in a row wow wow
this is all possible thanks to army
you're our universe the shout out to the
army was part of bts's acceptance speech
after winning favorite pop duo or group
and that was just one of their three
trips to the winner's circle sunday
night
the k-pop super group later nabbed
trophies for artist of the year and
thanks to this smooth jam best pop song
thank you butter has received so much
love this year this award
truly proves that
this song reaches many people's hearts
never take for granted thank you so much
and get this here's comedian liza koshy
having zero chill as she announced the
group one for artist of the year
yeah
i'm deeply touched by mice
by this award of course bts couldn't let
the night end without a crowd-pleasing
performance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but before the show e.t caught up with
the big winners on the red carpet
bts what a huge night for you three
nominations two performances how are you
feeling
amazing it's amazing for me we waited
this for
so
so long time so it's like a dream yeah
it's like a dream i mean we actually
dreamed of this dream so it's crazy
i mean like we're just here to have a
good time with the armies with the
actual people not ais not the robots
you can stop dreaming because this is
reality you are living in this well
deserved moment and tonight's host cardi
b she says that her daughter culture
loves you guys my daughter she she loves
bts i like her to listen to bts because
you know they're like more like
friendly and they make her dance and all
that stuff so i know she's gonna be
excited to see them
what message do you have for little
culture hey
let's do it again
you know what's up that's the culture
right there let's go